Speaker 1: Let's go next to Shelly from
Indiana. Shelly, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Or are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 3: My question is about the Trump
administration. Sure. A lot of times during and
after you would hear Trump supporters say about
all of his accomplishments, but when you would
ask them, what are they? A common response is,
well, I'm not going to tell you, you
need to do your own research sometimes.
Speaker 1: I mean, sometimes they will
actually generally say, well, look,
he did the economy and he cut regulations
and he dealt with all these great. You know,
he dealt with countries and he fixed the
border. You know, they'll just say things
that aren't true. That's another possibility.
Speaker 3: Well, in my so my question was,
were there any major accomplishments
in the Trump administration
that that you could actually point to?
Speaker 1: Well, there's a couple a couple
of things. I mean, I think that the first step
act and the criminal justice reform that he did.
Contained some positive initiatives to some
degree. You know, it's not a reason to elect the
guy, but he did kind of stumble, I think, thanks
to some of the people that were around him into
a couple of modest improvements there. I think
that Trump's tax plan, lowering the threshold at
which medical expenses become deductible was was
a good thing. You know, the tax plan overall was
a disaster. You know, I mean, it's like I can
find a couple of little things here and there.
Speaker 3: And yeah, that was it. I just,
I, I hear a lot from people that, oh,
you know, people on the left, they
don't, they don't want to notice
accomplishments when, when there's up in, um.
Speaker 1: Yeah. No, listen, I mean, I, I'm
glad to acknowledge accomplishments if that's
really what they are, but a lot of times it's
just they're not really accomplishments, you know?
What do you think his biggest accomplishment was?
Speaker 3: You don't know him.
Speaker 1: You don't know? Yeah. I mean, it's
tough to think of him. All right, Shelly. Things
are okay in Indiana. They're not too insane.
Speaker 3: So it's going well. I live
in the in the other America, so. All
right. It's been like a chain of flags over here.
Speaker 1: Shelly, you're breaking up a little
bit, but it sounded like you said not too
many Trump flags where you are. I really
appreciate the call. Okay.
Speaker 3: Okay. Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right. There is Shelley from
Indiana. The Internet tubes must not be super
wide there, which is why we were having an
issue. I'm going to take a very quick break.
If you are holding. Don't hang up because I'm
going right back to the phones in a moment.